the jurogan experience um
how much pushback have you gotten from
this idea because it seems like
a lot of people think that
overpopulation is a
giant problem and then when you say we
should triple
plus the amount of people in the united
states we want to compete with the rest
of the world
i would imagine a lot of people are like
what are you smoking matthew iglesias no
that i mean the book's really good so
everyone who reads it is just like oh
you convinced me and this is
there's no pushback at all um no i yes
uh there is
concern about overpopulation that's
something that
you know so there's people from the
right they don't like immigrants they
don't like immigration
why do they see it through that let's
start with that because this is a
country of immigrants it's a it's a very
strange thing
to have a country that is entirely
comprised of people who came from
somewhere else other than native
americans
right entirely comprised and yet
there's a giant population that doesn't
like immigrants
yeah i mean look some of it's a question
of taste you know people like different
places people like different kinds of
things
i think the best parts of america are
places that have a lot of people from
different places
to me you know whether that's that's
austin where we are
new york where i'm from it's like it's
cool like that's america at its best
some people don't like it uh there's
also the legality question though right
starting in the 1980s and 1990s we built
up a substantial group of people who
were living here
illegally i'm for you know what started
in the 80s is that when it really
started
yeah i mean that's when it really took
off was it because the regulations were
made more stringent well so what
happened was in 1996
uh they they changed the law they said
irera is the acronym for it
and they made it a lot harder for people
who had come here without papers
to quote unquote get legal so even if
you put roots down even if you were
married to an american citizen
there was no way to obtain legal status
they also made it harder to cross the
border so it used to be
people would come over they'd pick
vegetables in california for a season
and then they'd just go back right
they'd go back to mexico take their
money with them
get a nice house they made it harder to
cross the border so people would stay
and people who stayed had no way to get
a legal status here
so unauthorized population it built up
it built up it built up
there's a movement on one side to say
well we should create a path to
citizenship for those people most of
them
they're living here peacefully they're
working hard they're not doing anything
that's where i stand but there's people
who say look you know they broke the
rules we got to be harsh so we've been
arguing about that unauthorized
immigration
so viciously and i think we've lost
sight of the fact that you know we can
just create
legal pathways for people to come you
know some people will say
well my my grandparents my parents
whoever they they came the right way
they they didn't easy then exactly
and it's totally true so my
great-grandparents they came to this
country
at a time when there was no restriction
yeah my parents as well they just came
over from italy
yeah not that hard so good for them
right and so like yes like we should
have a legal process
for people to come we can have rules you
know try to make sure
you're like say you should be working
age right you should come here
get a job pay taxes you can't just like
come across and collect social security
yeah fair enough but obviously you're
okay with children
coming across as well like whether
they're adopted
once they get here or whether they come
here with their parents or
i mean we should make it possible right
yes we should make it possible that's a
great way of putting it and that's how
you can not have people
breaking the rules that's to me but you
know a lot of people on the right don't
see it that way now on the left
there's some folks you know people are
concerned about the environment
yeah i mean i'm concerned too i don't i
don't want to breathe polluted air i
don't want like cities underwater
uh but there's a strain of sort of
eco-apocalyptic thinking
you know where people say oh like we
can't handle it like only
degrowth is gonna is gonna save us and i
i just don't think that's right you know
i am bullish
on technology right we've got more and
more clean energy sources we've got
better and better electric cars
there's more stuff we can do with
electrification we need to take those
steps
but we can have a prosperous sustainable
society
that has plenty of people in it that has
high living standards
uh things like that so we don't need to
worry about that a lot of americans also
just
overestimate how many people are here so
a billion
sounds like a lot it's it's about triple
our current population
but that would give us the population
density of france
it would give us about half the density
of germany uh way less than half the
density of the united kingdom
and you know if you've ever been to the
uk it's like it's a nice country they
got
london big city they got countryside
they got rolling hills they got sheep
you go up to scotland like there's
[ __ ] nobody there
um so like we could have all kinds of
places
with a billion americans countryside
suburbs cities
all kinds of stuff what's the benefit of
having all those people though
uh so two benefits right so one i think
internationally you know the united
states has been
like the number one country for 100
years give or take right
uh we're the the biggest dog out there
you know no everybody knows better than
to mess with us
and we're losing that status you know
we're losing that status economically
to china they're doing more stuff like
you know
telling nba coaches like what they can
tweet what they can't tweet
they're censoring hollywood movies
because they've got the number one
market out there
you can get into scarier stuff
eventually you know
south china sea naval battles i'm not
like a war guy
but yeah you don't want that i think i
think we want to stay number one and
growth has been important to that
historically right like
why is the united states a big deal
country
and canada is like you know like our
cute little brother
and it's because a lot of people live
here you know canada's nice but there's
no people
no real strength there second i think
it'll make us a more
prosperous country uh what we do as
modern-day americans is we do stuff for
each other right whether that's we make
show we write books
uh we we teach in schools we run
restaurants we're doing services to each
other
and you get more prosperity when you
have more people
and more ability to sort of have those
interactions
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video and
audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience